is it true that you have a special pair
of Crocs that you only wear on stage and
were those featured at all in the
special well you know what's funny that
used to be true no let me let me let me
rephrase that that that is true now I
used to wear my Crocs to the club and
then change into shoes before I went on
stage MH and change back in the Crocs
and then I think it was um I think it
was Andrew Schultz that was like why
don't you just wear the Crocs on stage
that's I mean that's what you want to do
you know cuz he asked me why like why do
you do that I'm like Oh my the shoot the
shoes hurt my feet I got you know and
he's like why don't you just wear the
Crocs then I'm like you know that's not
a bad idea who gives a